The Dude abided once, so why
hasn't he abided again? We're
just dropping in to see what
condition his sequel is in.
Not only did Joel and Ethan Coen write and direct
some of the most critically acclaimed films of
the 1990s and 2000s, but they made a lot of them,
quickly. After the release of "The Big Lebowski"
in 1998, the duo churned out 11 movies over the
next 20 years. However, one thing they've never
done — and might never do — is a sequel to any
of their works, especially "The Big Lebowski."
It is worth noting, however, that there was
a theoretical "Barton Fink" follow-up they
kicked around called "Old Fink," so a sequel
is not entirely impossible… just unlikely.
So what's the resistance here? According to
the Toronto Star, when asked about another
"Big Lebowski" movie at the 2013 Cannes
Film Festival, Joel Coen told reporters,
"I just don't like sequels."
To seemingly put a nail in that
coffin, Ethan Coen admitted,
"I don't see it in our future."
"This will not stand."
Further complicating a proper start on the
"Big Lebowski" sequel is the fact that Joel
and Ethan Coen have entered a new phase
of their working relationship. In 2021,
Joel went solo and directed "The Tragedy
of Macbeth." Ethan followed suit,
making "Drive-Away Dolls"
with his wife, Tricia Cooke.
However, it was recently revealed that
the Coens haven't permanently ended
their cinematic partnership. In the
August 2023 issue of Empire Magazine,
Ethan revealed that he and Joel are working on
a new project together. Chances are almost zero
that it's a sequel to "The Big Lebowski," but if
the brothers are making movies together again,
perhaps one day we might get
more bowling alley adventures.
Needless to say, Jeff Bridges is totally down
for "The Big Lebowski 2." When People asked
about the possibility of a follow-up film
in May 2023, the legendary actor replied,
"Oh god! If the brothers were involved,
I certainly would. The brothers, they're
mysterious and full of surprises. [...] I don't
think they'll make a sequel. But like I say,
they're surprising, so maybe they'll
surprise me and make a sequel."
But what about the rest of the cast? Well, in
February 2011, Tara Reid — who played kidnapping
"victim" Bunny Lebowski — told Hollywood TV about
all the future projects she had lined up and said:
"We'll be doing 'American Pie 4' this
year and 'Big Lebowski 2' this year."
Of course, there was one major problem with that
statement — there was no such "Lebowski" sequel in
development. Upon hearing this, a blindsided Ethan
Coen quipped to the Austin American-Statesman,
"I'm glad she's working on it."
An employee of Reid's told Entertainment Weekly
that their boss was likely confused by comments
Jeff Bridges made a few months earlier. He had
publicly advocated for a new "Lebowski" movie,
but he'd also admitted that such a
film wasn't actually in the works.
Still, Reid appears to be on board, and she and
Bridges aren't the only ones who'd be down to take
another crack at their kooky characters.
Sam Elliott — who played the Stranger,
the sarsaparilla-drinking narrator
and passive participant in "The
Big Lebowski" — would also very much
like to film a follow-up. When asked
by Variety in 2017 if he'd be willing
to make the sequel, Elliott replied,
"In a heartbeat."
In 2014, some Coen fans believed
they were going to get what they
always wanted. In September of that
year, The National Report claimed
that Joel and Ethan Coen had confirmed
shooting would begin shortly on a "Big
Lebowski" sequel. The report also included an
alleged statement from Ethan Coen that read,
"We're thrilled to be coming back to film a second
part to this classic movie. For years we've
been staying away from doing this project,
but when we received this new script and the
cast fell into place, it was a no-brainer."
According to Snopes, the story spread fast on
social media and other far-reaching websites
before the general public realized it wasn't
true. And considering how the Coen brothers
almost exclusively pen the movies they direct,
the part about receiving a new script should've
been a dead giveaway. As it turns out,
The National Report was a faux-news site,
and it even included a disclaimer alerting
readers to the "fictitious" nature of its stories.
While there are no official concepts for a
true sequel to "The Big Lebowski," this hasn't
stopped interested parties from speculating
on the plot of such a project — including
the Dude himself. "Lebowski" star Jeff
Bridges wants the Coens to pursue a film
about his character's offspring.
He told Business Insider in 2016,
"I'm hoping they make a little Lebowski
because it's all set up. I impregnated
Maude. As the Stranger says, 'There's a
little Lebowski on the way,' you know?"
"It really tied the room together."
While no officially sanctioned sequel to
"The Big Lebowski" has ever been greenlit,
written, produced, or even approved
by the original film's creators,
the movie has inspired some
low-key and unconnected spinoffs.
Jeff Lebowski drinks White Russian cocktails
as a matter of course, but in a 2019 Super
Bowl commercial for Stella Artois, he tried one of
the company's beers and enjoyed it. Jeff Bridges
reprised his role of the Dude for the ad, and
he even wore the character's memorable costume.
Of course, there's also a feature-length film
set in the world of "The Big Lebowski" — a
little indie flick titled "The Jesus Rolls"
— though the Coen brothers had nothing to do
with making it. Instead, the 2019 film
was written and directed by actor John
Turturro as a way to once again portray his
"Lebowski" character — convicted sex offender
and foul-mouthed master bowler Jesus Quintana.
"The Jesus" is the only connection to "The Big
Lebowski," as the film is otherwise about the
character's post-prison release crime spree,
and it actually borrows more from the French film
"Going Places" than its Coen brothers predecessor.